hey leute herzlich willkommen zum
zweiten video das ich hier aus dem
urlaub mache das video wird also ein
bisschen zweigeteilt und zwar habe ich
einmal eine bestrafung die ich noch
machen muss von luca die kommt am ende
vom video also wenn ihr die sehen wollt
dann bleibt gerne dran und im ersten
teil des videos möchte ich so ein
kleines spielchen machen und zwar mit
meinem bruder da werde ich ein paar
sätze durch google translate also den
übersetzer von google schicken und dann
am ende wieder zurück auf deutsch
übersetzen das klingt jetzt sehr komplex
aber es ist eigentlich ziemlich simpel
also sobald ihr das zum ersten mal seht
bisher wahrscheinlich sofort wie das
funktioniert okay dann will ich sagen es
geht los
esp ist jetzt auch am start wir haben
den laptop mit dem wir das ganze spiel
werden hier folgendermaßen machen wir
das also einer von zweien überlegt sich
einsatz schickt ein paar mal durch
google translate und dann raten wir den
ursprung satz gewinnt derjenige der als
erstes drei sätze richtig geraten hat
und ich würde sagen ich beginne einfach
mal so leute also einmal habe ich das
jetzt in eine andere sprache übersetzt
von der sprache mal einfach hierhin ist
hier schon sehr simpler satz ich denke
weil es schwieriger gesetzt werden desto
größer werden die die schwierigkeiten
für den google translator die zu
übersetzen kennt die hälfte der sprachen
überhaupt gar nicht und das sieht schön
kurz aus so als wäre das nicht der der
ursprung gewesen
hier also und leute jetzt versteht ihr
leute jetzt versteht ihr wahrscheinlich
warum das so schwierig ist du kannst
gerne mal schauen sebastian und ich bin
ängstlich pirat und was könnte der
punktgewinn ist so eine art stille post
also ich bin denke ich mal der richtig
hinbekommen wie das sollte klein das hat
eigentlich klappen also ja gut dass herr
von raten dann würde ich sagen ich bin
ein
du wolltest doch bestimmt sagen ich bin
ein furcht haben als übergroße nicht
nein gar nicht so schwer
ich bin ein ok warte ich bin ein
tapferer kapitän
nein ich bin ein grausiger pirat ich
habe diesen satz gekommen bin hätte so
etwas macht freude wird das macht
überhaupt keinen sinn was du sowas
denken okay leute das sollte nicht noch
mal überdenken
lasst uns auch noch der regel machen
darf nur dreimal durch translate
schicken nur dreimal nur dreimal traf
fünfmal gewann hier bisschen zu viel
ich dachte der piraterie verhauen weil
ich mir nicht vorstellen konnte dass
österreich ein skiurlaub wird irgendwann
irgendwas op anschreiben das ist
eigentlich eine echt lustige idee weil
google translate verhaut die sachen so
unmenschlich
[Musik]
drei mal übersetzen ist die neuregelung
spannend wie lange wir das spiel müssen
bis wir tatsächlich dann was er hat wie
wir erst einmal mit malaga verstehst du
dich also einfach das nichts kopieren
erkennen lassen und was übersetzt
erkennen er hat richtig erkannt
ja er kann man auch erkannt dann jetzt
immer hier über sodann sagen zeig mir
mal wenn es so weit ist wird last schon
so dass wahrscheinlich wir über upgrade
machen große videos also ich sag ich mal
ganz schnell aus apa/red macht
großartige videos nein nein das war im
sinne ist es für sie apa/red macht gute
videos groß also kurze anmerkung aus dem
schnitt solche sachen zählen doch wir
haben uns da noch mal unentschieden aber
das sage ich euch nur ja schon mal dass
ihr euch nicht wundern kocht wie das ist
dass leute wo gold zweimal durch
geschenke gleich brechen ist schon
besser ab meinst du mit ihr im le canard
103 mal irgendwas erraten guckt man aus
chur du heute schon mal sein sagt schon
mal als heute heute hat es geschneit
falsch wir sind heute ski gefahren
das habe ein erster gedanke diese heute
schon gefallen aber ja aber ich dachte
mir es kann nicht sein dass sie so viele
wörter räumte schwere nur das spricht
gibt es wahrscheinlich aber keinen
schnee deshalb land heute schon so ist
sicherlich die sprache vom australischen
ich bin sehr gespannt ob wir auch nur
eins richtig raten können sowie das
gerade läuft ich würde sagen machen sie
aber sinngemäß also so dass wir sagen
hey du hast gesagt hat macht großartige
videos und der satz war ab und macht
gute videos dann ist das schon okay okay
also aber also es hat geschneit und wir
heute schief hat kriegt dann rückwirkend
dem kriegsflotte die wollen nämlich
gleich auch noch davon der folge für
sebastian aufnehmen für seinen kanal die
werde ich euch auch verlinkten
wahrscheinlich kommen die in etwa
zeitgleich online und da könnt ihr auch
vorbeischauen okay dann geht man im
nächsten satz sein
nebenbei ein bisschen was zu der
bestrafung von luca sagen wahrscheinlich
viele von euch wundert warum die gäste
noch nicht gekommen ist war eigentlich
sollte gestern hochladen es war mir
einfach zu peinlich
also es ging darum ich habe eine
challenge oder besser gesagt zum quiz
gegen luca verloren und deshalb musste
ich in unserem hotel mitten in die
menschen stellen wenn sie gerade essen
und brüllen abonniert konkreter und das
machen wir doch eine nummer zu hart vor
allen dingen weil wir die leute aus dem
hotel kennen die dort wahrscheinlich
auch kein bock drauf an beim essen so
gestört zu werden ist habe ich das heute
leicht anders gemacht aber ihr seht ihr
am ende frei übersetzung haben wie
gesagt ja heißt dass man davon der
andere dann wieder eine andere dann
wieder zurück weil es nicht übersetzen
oder davon drei brände sprache möglich
machen kann glaub ich hab schon wieder
so das kann gar nichts werden
ich esse ein leckeres dessert
ich esse christus her kanisch vollkommen
richtiger satz aber eigentlich die
türkei nicht die ursprüngliche bedeutung
war
ich esse ein leckeres bommer und
wettbewerbsrecht
[Musik]
dass der ursprung ich weiß nicht was ich
esse leckere bonbons oder so irgendwie
sowas oder sowas
in somalia gibt wahrscheinlich
ausschließlich bonbon das egal
das ist mein zweiter punkt alter ich hab
mich gerade ob ich dumm bin weil
irgendwie habe ich mir diesen satz
angeschaut und dachte mir ist es etwas
ganz anderes aber soll ich bin stolz
dass man einmal übersetzt einmal
übersetzt und jetzt nur noch kurz ein
kariertes hemd ich bin nur die reichen
fendt max wenn du benutzen sagt das
klingt für mich jetzt als normaler
bürger also bis befremdlich dass es
benutzen heißt benutzt was stellst du
satz mit einem wenn die ausnahme weiß
zieht es den ausschlag so rücker und
treibt man körper an den händen film so
richtig schmutzig auf kritik
das heißt dass so ein gerät das hemd
trägt also ich trage ein kann ist ja
dass der exakte wird steckt schreibt mal
alle wenn ihr immer noch dran seit
google spiel in die kommentare
das wäre lustig dankeschön gern nach
vorne gefahren das daraufhin ganz klar
aber ich bin jetzt hier vor nicht kann
ich drauf schauen
du kannst auch was drauf geschaut ja
aber ich hab dich warf er selbst gesagt
zusätzlich zum schnitt gesehen und eine
art abgeschnitten
immer wenn etwas gut läuft dann sagt mir
ich okay das erlebst du niemals hier
machte ok wobei du hast schon recht ein
bisschen schwer tun also der satz ist
auch dort deutsch ein bisschen
ungewöhnlich steht auch das dach wurde
also was ist nicht falsch eines sonne
sind einfacher satz aber damals das
zusammenspiel man weiter fällt nicht so
übersetzte erstmal in würde
ach du scheiße walisische damit so hayes
und kommt eher wahrscheinlich auch wie
flüssig bis in walisische das hört man
sagen
das von walisischen als beide sich
übersetzen qualität
er sagt das sei deutsch aber ich
deutschen mehr dann macht man mit dieser
setzte kommt vista nun in tango
synthiepop also übersetzt hat deutsch
und ich will mir mein glück okay war die
erste das waren deutsch noch walisischen
ein walisischer als deutscher kanzler
verließ er zurück okay das war's dann
machen wir doch politisch gut dann
zurück auf deutsch
und übrigens danke ein jahr für die
video hallo herr weiter
das bild zeigt den wald von menschen
aha leute ich glaube so abseits ist es
gar nicht welcher fall ist so ein bild
von einem weiterleben menschen dran
bild zeigt den weit von menschen das
handelsübliche deutscher satz oder das
abi oft hatte ich glaube das spiel zeigt
einen weit mitmenschen posten ich weiß
das bild zeigt ein wald aus menschen oha
aber von also ein einziges kleines bord
ist falsche sascha als wir haben gar
nicht mehr reise um die welt gemacht der
wüste einfach
nach walisisch dann zurück nach kurdisch
und jetzt gerade aber eigentlich auch
punkte
wenn wir jetzt anfangen wegen von und
aus unterschiede machen das auch durch
das schon punkt wenig wasser wichtige
rolle sagt das bild zeigt ein wald mit
menschen habe ich erreicht
das besagt ein daumen zeigt anwalt aus
menschen ist aber eine falsche
beobachtung
die leute stehen hier einmal dabei ein
dritter die leute sollen bäume selbst
sein
nein doch richie rich mit der materie
und erkennen was dir mal doch eine wie
gesagt es ist nicht wahr mir gesagt
eigentlich sein was hast du es nach 1 2
sind der nied ii schon schon drei die
ich habe das heißt ich habe gewonnen
hast du schon gegeben naja aber auch die
möglichkeit dich auf deinem kelsterbach
ii
heißt also falls ihr gerade fahne das
ist unfair ist dass ich im punkt
bekommen habe oder so wir nehmen es
jetzt zum allerersten laufen aber es
nicht irgendwie woanders übernommen oder
so also gibt es keine festen regeln und
wir müssen jetzt irgendwie so ein
bisschen ja uns was überlegen ich finde
es auf jeden fall extrem lustig wenn ihr
davon noch eine folge sehen wollt als
erstes mal bei sebastian auf dem kanal
und falls ihr dann immer noch bock habt
dann schreibt das gerne mal die
kommentare und dann macht ihr euch noch
ein video davon und jetzt kommen wir zu
dem teil wo sich wahrscheinlich sehr
viel drauf gefreut haben
ich habe das ganze auf einer alm gemacht
das heißt beim skifahren oben auf dem
berg da waren auch genug leute außen
herum die mich auch zum teil ziemlich
bild angeschafft aber ich wollte es
einfach wirklich nicht im hotel machen
ich hoffe mal luca falls du das jetzt
siehst du bist damit zufrieden falls
nicht dann wenn wir irgendwann nochmal
ein quiz machen und dann werde ich dir
die ekelhafteste change aller zeiten
gehen weil ich war mir wirklich
unangenehm und ja dann würde ich sagen
zeige ich erst mal das video leute wir
sind gerade beim skifahren auf einer alm
und vielleicht mache ich jetzt endlich
meine bestrafung weil ich wollte sich im
hotel machen weil so viele regeln zu
erkennen
und vielleicht macht es jetzt einfach
hier gleich wenn wir abbauen
wir tun es jetzt läuft es ist soweit
sebastian wird es finden heute
laut uvek und verstecken uns hinter dem
fonds stecken zitiert am pfosten mattes
vorne
also lasst mich sein wollte aber ich hab
es gefährlich hobbys zählen weiters
davon irgendwann nochmal einen change
gibt dann rechts geheimzahl hatte war es
in ordnung die lautstärke
es haben sich schon alle umgeguckt kein
problem das wir ganz im neuen abonnenten
gewonnen hast jetzt werden